good morning John what is going on here
this is the dr. pepper can and it's
never been opened and it is doing this
it feels like it's super thin like it's
a weird aluminum but it's only because
aluminum cans are actually they're very
fragile except that they have high
tensile strength so when they're being
inflated by the pressure inside of them
actually get quite strong when they're
not they're weak and floppy but this is
never leaked it's never been open but
it's not got pressure in it so let's
open the normal one so that sound of
normal what's up in this my guess is
it's gonna sound different yeah this is
a flat dr. pepper what's happening
normal dr. pepper
it tastes like regular dr. pepper and
then this barest tiniest tingled
authentic blend of 23 flavors but a
missed one so I guess the carbonation is
necessary to make a coke can feel like a
coke can otherwise when it gets cold all
of the gas inside contracts and then you
get a weird deflated coke can guess if
anybody has any better theories than
that let me know John I've been thinking
a lot about stories recently because
I've been working on my own because I've
just read yours and because it's the day
after the 30th anniversary of Star Trek
The Next Generation the most formative
piece of media in my life so there's a
guy who I never thought about when I was
a young person didn't know he existed
but who had a tremendous impact on me
Michael piller was the showrunner for
Star Trek The Next Generation from the
third season to the end of the show the
last couple years he shared that Duty
with Jerry Taylor his people wrote a lot
happens with the Star Trek but also
managed the writing room show running is
the thing that back then in the 90s
wasn't thought about by normal people
certainly not by me I was like 11 I was
just watching an interview with Michael
piller today and he was saying that they
once went in with an idea for a show and
talked to Gene Roddenberry the creator
of Star Trek about and the episode was
like an adventure as chase across the
universe and gene said what's it about
they're like well it's about an
adventurous chase across the universe
that's the thing about Star Trek next
generation the thing that I don't find
too often these days in TV sci-fi is
that it was always about something like
it was about the plot but I feel like
they're gonna sacrifice plot or meaning
they were gonna sacrifice plot first
it's so easy to write a story about good
versus evil and spaceships blowing up
it's hard to write a story about
disability or racism or what it means to
be human or like super cheesy stuff like
the value of honesty right that's a hard
thing to write about these days like
we're no longer the west wing world we
are the house of cards world and I'm a
little bit sick of it and I think it's
kind of boring I want to know what's it
about and if you tell me it's about how
messed up the world is and just evil
people doing evil things I'm done I'm
done with it
I don't want it anymore any stories that
are about something and something that I
can be hopeful about maybe I mean it's
hard right don't get me wrong when
people ask me what's turtles all the way
down about the first thing I think about
isn't the plot which is great like it's
very interesting like he kept me hooked
throughout the whole book it's the
themes it's how do we maintain
relationships with people who have
problems with their brains how do we
understand people who experience the
world in fundamentally different ways
than we do how is that a thing with
people's brains just working differently
but also in a world with such dramatic
inequality as we have right now you know
nothing about what happens in the book
from what I said but maybe you know what
it's about which is a thing I feel like
we're not necessarily asking ourselves
in today's media enough I think I
learned from Star Trek next generation
which I hope you all will join me in
watching a ton of this weekend on
Netflix themes are as important
sometimes more important than plots
diversion is kind of the least of what a
story can offer us we have to think
about the stories that our world is
built upon and that ourselves are built
upon which is it turns out a great way
to create media whether it's video blogs
or books or TV shows Jon I'm really
proud of you and your book I can't I
wait for other people to read it and
I'll see you on Tuesday